[Music]
in violent gaming news oh no such thing
submitted by Michaels hooker which one
out of the many rest of always one came
out I know the rest are we maybe it's
number 237 maybe Michael okay
psychologist claims the video game
pac-man is just as violent as doom who's
this [ __ ] idiot that's another tie
remember dildo was fun either some old
games good that game you can have it on
a [ __ ] floppy disk yeah doom was like
the first person shooter I think or no I
think Wolfenstein was oh I thought the
duck hunter would know I smell something
ah it's a little bit different as a
person around you like in this dungeon
you're killing all these monsters comes
different weapons and I [ __ ] hated
the sound the [ __ ] pac-man good I
never like like that I got a little
warning spot pac-man made me more
violent than the other games because it
frustrated yeah it's fresh so [ __ ]
boring
it is really boring and then like the
when you're 20 before you eat one of
those tokens you have this [ __ ] ghost
that's trying to like be all up on you
right and then as soon as you eat a
token they turn into these little
[ __ ] I'm like get the [ __ ] back here
what happened a second ago you wanted to
start some [ __ ]
all of a sudden eat this [ __ ] thing
and he turn it to low [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know those little ghost things
they're like you
they're like bullies like they are like
they want to slap you in the face and
then when you return a punch they tell
on you
yeah tries to guess on that I mean you
go and eat them yeah a little out of his
[ __ ] cycle all just saying well I
think you guys are gonna agree with what
he's saying
so this psychologists name is Patrick I
disagree mark key and that's a good okay
and so he's saying that he doesn't think
that there's evidence to link violent
games to real-life violence and so he
created this book called moral combat
why the war roll call
smells like one of those Christian songs
where they try to like turn rap into
like a Christian oh my god dude you know
there was a group though called gospel
gangsters they had it was legit
difficult not to like them because their
beats were on point that's dope it was a
rock band I like gospel gangsters that
was like that they were Christian I'm
like what om EXPN oh yeah I forgot they
were Christian yeah I saw was it I don't
remember I just remember the name of the
Mexican Mexican xpx I really liked the
minute it was a vision this is not evil
am i found out that they were Christian
like ooh
I was like I like to anymore and
subconscious I just stopped like yes
because you're saying don't be trying to
brainwash me with it yeah like you try
to trick me it worked
nunim Allah you know p OD - they're
really religious you read it I never
like many other lyrics that song dog was
motivational man all those lonely boys -
the one song that they had at one hit
but they had uh-huh yeah oh okay
so anyways accident I like that Jewish
reggae good night yeah Matisyahu Oh
making me so Jewish he got me reading
the Cabal I don't know all of that's
Jewish is it I think that's to shred the
Cabal and that is a villain in mortal
combat though there's a vector more of
Gaza and so the newest book is moral
combat why the war on violence for video
games is wrong but the entire scheme of
it what's happening what are your
another perspective
yeah you always hear this perspective of
like the violent video games makes you a
violent person it's cool to hear the
opposing art well let's hear this dumb
[ __ ] you still against this dude no I
don't know what's going on same things
now I agree violent games don't do it
bad that
[ __ ] that that's what he's saying at
first I didn't like your statement but
now I like it because you twist it on
these [ __ ] asses go on
trophy yes he saw research does show
though that if people what did I miss
something there like a rubber band
laughing okay so research does show that
people are more likely to commit small
acts of aggression
after playing violent video games yeah
like Cola remote control a window or
something like that when they lose of
course that's not that's why I don't
play me that make sense I mean you do
that after everything like people losing
handball captions in mind yes more
gentleman yeah yeah and so he's saying
so this author is saying or psychologist
is saying that he is skeptical about
that research because of the fact that
every time they do a research on a
violent game they'll use so what they'll
do is they'll have you people in the
study is played for about 15 minutes of
gaming so it's not even all that long
and then they'll have them through like
some sort of X so for example there is
one act that they had to serve tacos
they have to make tacos for people that
hated hot sauce and so they would see
how much hot sauce they would put in
these tacos so that's like a small act
of aggression I don't even see the
[ __ ] correlation I don't see that I
shoulda made them go to sleep here you
play [ __ ] 30 minutes a Call of Duty
now go to sleep and see if they like it
they put the sheet rock take this
blanket I'm just I think the older the
issue that I have with these like sorts
of studies is that this is not something
that you can gauge in short-term amounts
you have to say yeah you have to see a
long period of time you have to get
these people who are already interested
in these type of games and see it
through a span of like 20 years and then
you know with the large group because
these things manifest later in life you
don't really know you know so anything
is that it's kind of embarrassing that
researchers don't have a good
operational definition on what a violent
game is so what he's saying is that for
most research researchers in the field
most rejecters those researchers in that
field they're saying that a violent game
is simply just when one character does
something to another character like kind
of hurts another character so what you
saying is that pac-man is the exact same
thing as doom then because you are
hurting like one character is hurting
another character that does promote
violence
exactly thank you okay I feel like I
think I think that by me game is for me
that might be a no-no for me is ones
that are too visceral and 2-wheel like
if it's like um you killing a monster in
pac-man or even like that kind of stuff
there's like this whole idea of it not
being a real person you know versus you
have these games where somebody's taking
it from the back and they're gutting a
human out like this
that's too visceral and that's like
stuff that even like like Call of Duty
that's something that happened in real
life so before my kid plays that they
have to understand what they're doing
and what their reenacting verse is if
you're like playing Halo and you're
shooting like alien in the [ __ ] face
you know what I mean that's where my
thing is like there may not be Studies
on it but that studies not to be done on
my kid first you know so let me figure
that out or my kid yeah when we used to
play pretend warriors or like soldiers
or something like that
we were stabbing the [ __ ] out of each
other and killing each other for real
we're just blasting each other and we
had some really good death scenes and
all that stuff it was really good is
your like a mensch adoption it's not
choreographed but sometimes the
imagination could be crazier that's true
because I think it's like it's not
really the video game putting those
thoughts into the kids minds they
already have it so regardless if there's
a video game or not like I remember
there's times where like we play playing
like war right and I kill my friend and
he's on the ground already so he already
died but my ritual wasn't over I still
have to behead him grab his head soccer
ball cut his arm off cut him in this gut
but then pull the skin apart plug all of
it lodges like he's already dead but
he's still playing a lot like Oh and so
all of that is in the kid's mind still
Danny
forever did that you are not a clear
great example but was there I'm there
with like a Dodgers a like baseball
helmet my sword is a [ __ ] tennis
racket like I look goofy as [ __ ] but
it's just in the mind yeah like I have
my dad's like necktie like off to the
side like it might look goofy but I
don't think it's yeah it's your
imagination right but it's obviously
coming from stuff that you've already
seen as a kid if you weren't doing
sexual things because your kids Chinese
kung fu movie cuz your kids I mean cuz
well your parents did a good job of
shielding you from anything sexual you
know it means it's not like you're like
Chinese coaching girls and like [ __ ]
like grabbing their asses you know
because you didn't see that I think it's
everything you've been exposed and then
there's also age ratings for games now
it's kind of like the movies so you
can't really buy games if you're like 12
or 11 that are like super gory like that
you go to game stop or whatever you they
won't they won't sell it to you
I don't mind kids to be in the games in
the first place yeah happy games huh be
in two games Your Honor I wanted to be
into like sports issue so when I was a
kid out in the sports circle activity
yeah like that I were playing football
playing basketball so I can tech Lundell
all into the [ __ ] and that's where my
focus slide and I did not really play
games as much that was a point where I
did play games here and there but then
again those were dark times so and
they're not on my mom try to do for us
too because we used to have like that
really old school like Nintendo and when
she saw that all of her kids were like
playing it a lot that's when she decides
to like unplug everything and just hide
it somewhere nowhere at all the [ __ ] no
no no don't hit it somewhere and then we
just didn't never really played it and
we just did outdoor stuff yeah Isaac
loved playing video games and I got our
play Pete he's really limited to how
much he can play and what he plays but I
hate it when he goes over to his dad's
house because he has an older cousin
who's four years older than him he has
all the rated M video games and he's
like playing like Call of Duty mobile oh
[ __ ] yeah he's like I love the zombie
mode I'm like what are you talking about
I told you you can't play these games
aguirre and I explained it to him to I'm
like listen I know you want to play
these games and I know you want to do
these grown-up things and
you've grown movies because the same
thing over there like they watch things
that you shouldn't be watching them like
not porn but like a grownup movies and
so um tell them like let your brain
isn't developed enough to understand
like what you're watching and what
you're what you're really absorbing
exactly I'm like yeah you might think
this is not cool right now but you don't
know like the kind of effects you might
have later on in your life of your brain
isn't ready for this so then I he comes
home and he tells me like well you're
right I shouldn't be playing these games
I shouldn't be watching those movies
because I had nightmares the whole time
I was in my dad's house on my you see I
told you like why don't you listen to me
like I know I gotta go to my best friend
is crazy my mom nah the game sucked when
I was the kid and only had like four of
them so once I get bored it's like I
can't talk the next level and they get
hard as hell too and you got to start
all the way from the beginning so I got
lucky but older games were a lot harder
dude they literally gonna give a [ __ ]
about your feelings yeah yeah they just
try to make it as no Super Mario games
are [ __ ] hard man yeah I supplied
duck hunt I'm like [ __ ] I can't [ __ ]
shoot these [ __ ] ducks I go up to the
I you know face you [ __ ] ducks
the dog will [ __ ] laugh at you [ __ ]
you bitched you [ __ ] hey guys
thanks for watching the last video make
sure to follow us on instagram @ JK film
to watch more videos right up there
[Music]